[Music]
russia as you may have heard faces
economic ruin over its brutal war on
ukraine and the rest of the world is
grappling with the financial fallout as
russia attacks continue congress is
moving forward with legislation to end
normal trade relations with the country
zanny mittenbedos is editor-in-chief of
the economist magazine and she joins us
now don't you call it a newspaper not a
magazine that's a typo we call it a
newspaper you're quite right you're
clearly an avid reader i am in fact i am
in fact that is true uh and so i'm very
interested to know what you think about
how these sanctions that we and the rest
of the free world are levying against
russia could actually come back and land
and be hard for us here
well they've been much bigger than
people expected they've been effective
and they've really decimated the russian
economy but you're right of course they
are having an impact here we've seen it
in oil prices we've seen it in gas
prices we've seen it in prices for a
huge number of commodities and the
reason is that although russia is only
the world's 11th biggest economy it is a
commodity giant it's a huge huge
producer of lots of these commodities
and that's coming back pushing up prices
here that'll feed into inflation and
inflation was already pretty high here
you know eight percent almost in in
february people are hurting when you go
to the grocery store when you go to the
gas station and that if this conflict
goes on if these sanctions are on for
longer and particularly if russia reacts
and imposes more sanction of its own
this is going to hurt people and just
one example which is really i find
striking russia and ukraine together are
almost 30 percent of international sales
of wheat
wheat is absolute staple in tons of
countries and that's going to be really
hit not just because of sanctions and
because ships can't get into the black
sea but because of the war nobody's
planting any wheat in ukraine right now
and so people think my colleagues have
looked at this they think this is the
biggest shock to global wheat markets
since the first world war potentially so
this is this we're going to notice this
when you go to the restaurant when you
go to the grocery store people will feel
more of this the longer it goes on who
doesn't seem to care about the sanctions
though zanny do you think he does well
he's i mean it doesn't seem to have
changed his strategy whatever that is it
hasn't but and it's worth emphasizing
though just how dramatic the hit to
russia has been i mean it's we've
noticed it here but in russia
the economy is being really decimated
it's being frozen almost frozen in
aspect and the transformation that putin
has done in that country in the last
three weeks he's basically turned it
into a completely fascist dictatorship
you've you've had reports on the kind of
news that russians get it's total
propaganda the whole time it's the fight
for the fatherland against the west
they're not getting this they're not
getting the story
he's actually still pretty popular he's
framing it as plucky russia standing up
up against the kind of fascists in
ukraine and the question is can he do
that as his economy keeps collapsing and
and i think the lesson of history
unfortunately is that dictators can hang
on for a long time
he can't win he can't afford to win but
he can't afford to lose either i think
that's absolutely right i think right
now putin can't win in the sense that he
can't do what he thought he was going to
do really easily roll into ukraine be
greeted as a liberator you know kind of
hold the country the extraordinary
resistance the extraordinary courage of
the ukrainians and frankly the relative
incompetence of the russian military has
meant that he can't win but he also
can't afford to lose because he has
framed this as a kind of existential
struggle and so he needs to people talk
about off-ramps the whole time right
people what was an off-ramp for him
i'm really worried that he doesn't think
about off-ramps he's a he's a um
he's kind of more of a bandit type of
thing and i told you earlier about this
extraordinary story that i think really
is telling about putin putin once about
20 years ago gave some long interviews
and he said one of the most formative
things of his childhood was an
experience he had in his apartment block
in what was then leningrad where they
were that he and his friends used to
chase rats up and down the stairwell it
sounds kind of gross
they were chasing men that was the way
they spent their time he chased a huge
rat into a corner and he said that rat
when it was cornered flew at me and
started chasing me he said i learned an
important life lesson i learned about
how people behave when that when they're
cornered i think he's now
in that and so i really worry about
escalation i think you know what's he
got to lose so things like you know
chemical weapons even tactical nuclear
weapons they are no longer beyond the
realm of possibility and that's
frightening
it is frightening absolutely real
quickly before we go uh millions of
ukrainians have fled to neighboring
countries what kind of impact will that
have on economies in europe
well a huge impact it's an extraordinary
it's almost three million people if this
goes on it'll be more it's very striking
the different welcome these people have
had compared to the syrians a few years
ago the eu i have to say the european
union has been amazing
it's going to be if they stay a huge
change enormous numbers of you know
ukrainians moving to to western europe a
huge shock for ukraine in in western
europe in the long run great right more
smart zany thank you very very much we
always appreciate when you're here thank
you